high performance chips are needed to
build our future whether it's for
artificial intelligence or driverless
cars the key to producing Advanced chips
is by generating extreme ultraviolet
light euv light is revolutionary because
it has a much shorter wavelength
compared to visible light this allows
euv light to create extremely small
structures on chips circuitry that's 10
000 times thinner than a strand of human
hair the more structures that are packed
onto a chip the more powerful the chip
becomes but the thing is euv light
doesn't occur naturally here on Earth
it's only found in outer space
so how do you generate euv light on
Earth that's where a powerful laser
comes into play a trump laser from
Germany no it has nothing to do with the
former U.S president this high-powered
laser strikes tiny droplets of the metal
tin in a vacuum chamber as they shoot
past we're talking about striking 50 000
droplets of tin in just one second the
giant laser Takes Two Shots at each
droplet the first flattens the tin the
second bigger pulse vaporizes the tin
creating a plasma that generates the
prized euv light upon impact at the
desired wavelength of 13 and a half
nanometers light is projected through a
blueprint of the pattern that will be
printed in a previous video I explained
how mirrors made by the German company
Zeiss Focus the pattern onto the Silicon
wafer which has already been coated with
a light sensitive chemical the wafer is
eventually split into little pieces of
micro
no other laser on the market can hit 50
000 droplets per second at precisely the
right moment not a moment too soon or
too late otherwise the impact will not
flatten the tin droplet so Trump's Light
Beam must be shaped in a very specific
way each laser pulse consists of a small
compact group of light particles hurled
at the tin droplets in a tight Bunch the
plasma that is generated is extremely
hot with a temperature of 220 000
degrees Celsius or 396 000 degrees
Fahrenheit which is 30 to 40 times
hotter than the surface of the Sun
the Trump laser is used in the Dutch
firm asml's huge machines that perform
the crucial step in the trip making
process of printing tiny patterns
circuitry on Silicon Wafers asml is the
only company that is currently capable
of building the world's most advanced
system needed to print ships its euv
lithography system less Advanced
machines its deep UV lithography systems
can still print quality chips just not
the most sophisticated kind think of it
this way if you were to write your name
with a highlighter in smaller and
smaller font in order to write an even
smaller font you would eventually need
to switch to a pen
so an euv lithography machine is like
that finer pen
if you own a relatively new smartphone
or a smart watch you've likely benefited
from euv lithography technology
so far China has not been able to get
its hands on these sophisticated
machines when President Trump was in
office he pressed the Dutch government
not to sell the most advanced machines
to China the Biden Administration has
continued putting pressure on asml amid
the ongoing ship war with China
Washington's sanctions in October banned
U.S citizens permanent residents and
green card holders from supporting the
development or production of advanced
chips at certain factories in China
which could affect hundreds of people
working for Chinese semiconductor
companies and perhaps it could force
them to choose between their citizenship
or their job
as a result asml sent a memo in October
instructing its U.S employees to stop
servicing Chinese customers the memo
says they are prohibited from providing
certain services to Advanced Fabs in
China until further notice a Fab refers
to a chip manufacturing plant asml has
several locations in China for research
and development manufacturing and
training however at present it does not
sell its most advanced euv systems that
use the Trump lasers to China
so a tightly connected group of European
companies rule the technological World
in many ways the Dutch company asml is
the only firm that manufactures Advanced
machines to build the circuitry for
high-end ships it relies on Trump lasers
to generate euv light to pattern the
finest lines on microchips and mirrors
from the German company Zeiss collect
and focus the euv light I've done videos
on all three companies which I'll link
to in my description other chip makers
then use their euv systems to
manufacture their own microchips Intel
Samsung and tsmc Taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company makes nearly all
of the world's most advanced chips tsmc
currently produces five nanometer chips
and is striving for next generation
three nanometer ones
so when we talk about the future of tech
Trump Zeiss and asml are critical pieces
of a puzzle that together are shaping
the World of Tomorrow it would be
impossible to build sophisticated ships
without brilliant Engineers if you'd
like to improve your science math and
Engineering skills brilliant is a
website and app filled with interactive
puzzles like these in this scientific
thinking course you have to figure out
what the light intensity will be after
light passes through all five filters I
know my viewers also really love
Brilliance computer science fundamentals
course such as this course on neural
networks I use brilliant myself and
especially enjoy their logic puzzles
it's made me a much better thinker and
Problem Solver there's something for
everyone on brilliant whether you're a
student or you're already working and
wish to brush up on what you already
know they've got a whole host of
interactive math courses which will help
you see numbers in a new light brilliant
is free for you to try out if you head
to the custom link in in my description
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people who use my link to sign up
will get 20 off Brilliance annual
premium subscription which gives you
unlimited access to all of their course
offerings thanks for watching for
newsthink I'm Cindy Palm